ce qui a des copines qui te manque
qu'est ce que tu aimerais que reviennent
d'accord nour a fait partie des huit
élèves présents ce mardi 26 mai dans
l'école maternelle pierre brossolette
des mureaux avec le respect des gestes
barrières écriture coloriage et jeux de
construction sont au programme
habituellement ils sont 102 enfants
accueillis chaque jour dans cet
établissement
ce qui est important c'est qu'il
retrouve les les personnes de l'école
qu'il retrouve les enseignants qu'ils
retrouvent les pratiques pédagogiques
qu'ils avaient et qu' il puisse refaire
ce qu'il avait fait avec leurs parents
avec les enseignants pour faire revenir
les élèves et assurer une continuité
pédagogique pour tous dans les écoles
maternelles et primaires le dispositif
deux aces de ces sports santé culture
civisme a été lancé par l'état des
activités éducatives en complément du
travail scolaire
l'intérêt c'est d'abord du lien du lien
collectif c'est un immense moyens de
ramener les élèves vers l'école ça nous
prépare également à ce qui se passera
pendant les vacances parce qu'on ne va
pas laisser les élèves et les jeunes et
les enfants pendant ses vacances sans
contact sans activité et sans vacances à
prenante puisque
nous y travaillons la commune des
mureaux a signé ce partenariat à partir
du 9 juin les élèves de la ville auront
deux jours d'enseignement et deux jours
d'ateliers deux aces de ces avec
plusieurs activités en collaboration
avec des associations de la ville qu'on
a une association qui est le fils du
développement durable ans qui va
intervenir sur tout ce qui est lié à
l'environnement notamment la gestion de
l'eau la gestion de la terre
on est en train de regarder aussi avec
des associations de danse qui ne sont
pas nécessairement dans le centre d
heure d'autres communes comme guyancourt
fontenay-le-fleury poissy et versailles
ont déjà contacté l'académie pour
bénéficier du dispositif